[Music]
we're trying to make sure we think
carefully and thoughtfully about how to
build these systems so not since we
might need to slow things down but we're
also trying to push the boundaries right
that means like coming up with new
techniques so we can then accelerate our
progress what are the new methodologies
and techniques and tools we need to
build so that we can still make rapid
progress but do so carefully you're
listening to the Microsoft Research
podcast a show that brings you closer to
the cutting edge of technology research
and the scientists behind it I'm your
host Gretchen using
[Applause]
[Music]
there's an old adage that says if you
fail to plan you plan to fail but when
it comes to a eye doctor Salima a mercy
a principal researcher and the adaptive
systems an interaction group at
Microsoft Research condense that if you
plan to fail you're actually more likely
to succeed she's an advocate of calling
failure what it is getting ahead of it
in the AI development cycle and making
end users a part of the process today
dr. Romer she talks about life at the
intersection of AI and HCI and does a
little AI myth-busting she also gives us
an overview of what and who it takes to
build responsible AI systems and reveals
how a personal desire to make her own
life easier may make your life easier to
that and much more on this episode of
the Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
Salima a mercy welcome to the podcast
things thanks for having me you work in
a group called the adaptive systems and
interaction group and you're a principal
researcher there tell us in broad
strokes what you do for a living and why
you do it what get you up in the morning
sure so I work at the intersection of
human-computer interaction and
artificial intelligence and so I create
technologies and techniques to help
people both build and use AI systems so
that means you know I think a lot about
developers and data scientists and the
tools that they can use to create our AI
systems but also the end users who
ultimately will use and interact with
the AI systems in their everyday lives
and so I think about how we can make
these systems and people interacting
with them more efficient and effective
and then more recently I've started to
think a lot more about responsible AI
and how we could help people interact
with these things safely and responsibly
so that they can trust them and use them
to help them in their everyday lives
right and so you know if I think about
what wakes me up in the morning it's
this responsible AI stuff it's both
exciting and terrifying you know there's
so much potential for AI to help people
and society but also a lot of potential
for harm so that gives me a lot of work
to do well before we get specific I want
to get a little geeky from an academic
point of view and talk about methodology
I don't talk about that much on the show
and I think it would be interesting to
kind of take a quick look at the tools
that you use to equip ml software
engineers with the tools they'll use so
a lot of my work involves designing and
building new interactive AI systems so
that means I end up using both design
tools and prototyping tools as well as
you know development tools and machine
learning tools to build AI models and I
think you know to build these systems
effectively you really need to
understand some of like how these AI and
machine learning systems work you know
you need to understand what knobs are
available to give to people so that they
can interact with them more effectively
so I think a lot of my work involves
actually like building and developing
system
and then in terms of methodologies I use
both qualitative and quantitative
methods you know I really like to
understand the needs of people before I
start building things that's really this
you know user centered design approach
right where you really like all your
decisions are based on user needs right
and oftentimes for that you use a lot of
qualitative methods interviewing
techniques and surveys to get that sort
of rich feedback but at the same time I
come from a math background so I really
like to see numbers and hard evidence so
I also do a lot of quantitative research
so controlled studies where we you know
statistically compare things so I can
you know trust my own work and
understand whether or not the things I
build actually help people I think there
are benefits and limitations to all
these methods you know if you use
quantitative techniques you really have
to control a lot of variables and that
means you can really only answer very
narrow question right right so yes you
can get statistical significance and
numbers but you don't really understand
qualitatively like why this is happening
and why is this working better for
people or not and I think I really like
to use both methods and all the work I
do and like to have a quantitative and
qualitative perspective because they
really feed into each other and that's
how you can really understand why things
are working or not let's get into your
work right now there's a lot of
discussion today about ethics in AI
think it's because we're starting to see
some of the ramifications of these
systems that we're putting out in the
real world and Microsoft has actually
been a leader in this space so I want to
talk about several threads of research
you've undertaken and the implications
of your findings and I want to start by
setting the stage and operationalizing
the term responsible AI or Rai
what is Rai and what does it look like
IRL in the real world I'm a really
practical person so to me responsible AI
is really all about the how right like
how do we design develop and deploy
these systems that are fair reliable
safe and trustworthy and all those
things
and to do this I really believe that we
need to think of responsibility I as a
set of socio technical problems okay so
that means that we need to go beyond
just data and models and making those
better we have to think about the people
who are ultimately going to be
interacting with these systems even if
you collect a really huge diverse data
set or and your models are tuned
appropriately if a person can't
effectively understand the AI or you
know take over control when it
inevitably fails that can also cause
problems so I think when we create
responsibility AI systems we need to
think about these systems responsibly
which you know opens up many challenges
but also new opportunities right I like
to say that failure has a lot of phases
and not all of them are ugly you take it
a step further and say that responsible
AI requires planning to fail why mm-hmm
yeah so this is something I've been
thinking about a lot lately and some
types of failures are really inherent
and unavoidable in AI so yes we should
be doing our due diligence and trying to
make sure we deploy systems that are you
know as error-free as possible that we
do bug them carefully we need to do all
that work but we also need to recognize
that we can never get rid of all of
these errors and that's by design so let
me I can give you an example so imagine
you know you have a facial recognition
system that's used for access control by
design an algorithm will be tuned to
optimize for some metric so maybe you
try to optimize for precision or recall
which really like affects the amount of
false positives and false negative
errors okay you can have you can never
really get rid of all of those errors
because by definition an AI model is a
simplification of the world you can
never fully capture the world so AI
algorithms are designed to do the best
under the circumstances and that means
it'll sacrifice parts of the input space
try to get something that's optimized
accordingly and so that means you will
definitely have some false positives and
false negatives the algorithm will try
to determine a model that generalizes
well to new data and may sacrifice parts
of the input space okay and so the
choice of parameters you use or
thresholds you use is really important
and you really need to think about the
user scenario there so if you get that
choice wrong that's going to be costly
to the users so in the
facial-recognition scenario false
positives are much worse than false
negatives right if somebody accesses
your account that can be much more
costly than if you have trouble
accessing it yourself so if you don't
get that right that's a failure in the
same sense you can't avoid all false
positives and false negatives so you
need to ensure that you give people
mechanisms to not only understand when
those are happening but also to override
the system or take over control when
they inevitably happen so if you can't
get into your system provide another
means of accessing your system that
doesn't rely on that technology so
anticipating those failures as designers
and developers if you recognize these
common AI failures and make sure you
design interfaces and your systems to
help people address those failures
that's how we can work towards creating
responsible AI systems go back to the
planning for failure then in the design
part of that what does that mean so
that's about I would say enumerated the
common types of AI failure so false
positives false negatives being
uncertain being only partially correct
but also again thinking of AI systems as
socio technical problems right so that
means going beyond just the model errors
themselves but places where the system
can fail in terms of how the user is
able to interact with them ok so again
like the mismatched expectations issue
right I would consider that a failure if
a person has higher expectations of the
system then it's capable of that's a
failure rate there has if a doctor is
relying on a system to make
recommendations about their patience if
they think that the system is smarter
than it actually is
they may over rely on it and that can
result in harms so what's the mitigation
there because you've got the system
that's going to fail is it more
educating up front this is where we can
get creative as an industry for some of
these we often go to let's just give
people all the documentation right like
list out everything but nobody reads
documentation I don't even read the apps
exactly right and so what are other ways
that we can sort of expose the
capabilities and limitations of these
systems we've done a lot of work in the
space and trying to understand what is
effective for this and other types of
failure so showing examples of the
variety of things that an AI system can
do effectively is a way of giving people
an understanding of their capabilities
giving people controls to turn the knobs
themselves that gives them an
understanding but it also makes them
part of the process and so they're sort
of more accepting when these things
inevitably break down and are more
willing to interact with them and
continue to interact with them because
they're part of that process
[Music]
let's zoom in and talk about responsible
AI writ large and kind of following up
on some of the points that you just made
about planning for failure and
understanding that these things fail I
know that there are some myths out there
about it and some hurdles that people
have to overcome both on the making side
in the using side so talk sort of
generally about what we're facing here
and what we need to do to build
responsibly what's what are the
necessary building blocks yeah this is a
great question and it's something we've
really started to look into recently
we've started to do some preliminary
work to understand sort of the
challenges people face and trying to
build responsibility I systems yeah and
also the perceptions that people have
about responsibility is use around like
bias and fairness and you know some of
the things that we hear about in the
news and some of what we've been finding
is really interesting there's a eyes now
that are being used to make hiring
decisions or recommendations so imagine
you're using an AI system to make
recommendations about who to hire for a
technology job or an engineering job you
know we've seen in the news sometimes
these systems can be biased and so maybe
your system is biased against
recommending women for engineering
positions if you ask people about this
fairness and bias issue a lot of people
will come and say you know well this is
just reality if we try to fix this we're
actually just adding our own biases and
who are me to change reality right and
this goes back to you know what I was
saying earlier which is that this is not
reality right like AI models are by
definition of simplification of the
world like we cannot represent the world
and all the factors that will impact
whether or not a person will be a good
hire we can't represent all of that and
so while it might be true that there's
you know gender disparity and technology
it's incorrect to say that this is
reality another thing
that we hear is that you know this is
just math right
AI is math ik so it can't be wrong you
know and yes it's true like the math is
designed to do what you tell it to do
but again going back to what I was
saying earlier the AI is designed to do
the best under the circumstances and
because you can't fully capture the real
world that means that it will try to you
know minimize errors not eliminate them
but minimize them right and so even if
the math is doing what it's supposed to
you know it's operating over data and
that data can be limited how you show
that information to the user can cause
problems and failures and so the math
might not be wrong but the AI system
overall could still be wrong right I
think we should think about these humans
and machines as having different error
regions right so yes each of these
systems will have uncertainty but
they'll be different and so ideally
those uncertainty regions don't overlap
that much right and then you can
complement each other effectively and
it's true because AI systems can see
things that people can't right and vice
versa right and so I think that's the
way we should be looking at these and
you know thinking about what is that
overlapping region and ensuring that
people understand sort of the
limitations of those systems and where
it might fail versus where you might
fail what are we facing on the making
end of this we're talking here about how
these systems operate with users are
there any challenges that we face as
developers I think this is where a lot
of the work needs to be done we have to
I think rethink how we go about building
these systems and a firm believer that
building responsibility AI systems
requires an interdisciplinary approach
and so for example a lot of times we put
a lot of our emphasis and resources
towards building better models and
getting better data but again you know
these are social technical systems so we
also have to think about how those
systems will be to
Floyd in the world and who is gonna
affect who are the different
stakeholders what are the implications
to those different stakeholders when
things go wrong and I think that really
requires a user-centered approach right
and so we should be leveraging you know
the skills and expertise of for example
our user researchers and designers who
have the training to sort of understand
the needs of people and that
understanding should be driving all of
our AI decisions including you know what
algorithms to use if you need a system
that can provide an explanation to a
user so that they can make an
appropriate decision you're gonna need
an interpretable model all right so
that's gonna affect the choice of
algorithm you use understanding the
users is going to affect the parameters
you choose the data you collect right
all those decisions should be driven by
the scenario and I think sometimes we do
it the reverse way in the industry right
we build technologies and then sort of
stick an interface on it and hope it
works for people but I think to do it
responsibly we need to do the reverse so
there's a level of opacity I think in
terms of form factor when we deliver an
AI system when I think of what I get now
it's a laptop it's a phone but inside of
that is where these AI systems are being
deployed and so I don't necessarily
differentiate between my phone that used
to do what it did and my phone that now
I can talk to or my phone that looks at
my face and says okay Gretchen you can
come in how do you think about design on
those things that alert users that
they're now dealing with AI and how do
you educate about that ai systems are
fundamentally different than our
traditional computing systems and I
think our practitioners and product
teams are sort of really struggling to
design effective systems because of
those differences what we know about how
to design effective traditional
computing systems like making sure your
interfaces are consistent or your
systems behave consistently so people
know how to use them know what to expect
that's something
that's inherently very difficult for AI
systems because they can operate
differently in subtly different contexts
or from one user to the next how do we
design for that right like I think we
need to come up with a lot more guidance
to help our teams understand what is an
effective way of designing these systems
so people can interact with them
effectively right bill Buxton design
guru here at Microsoft Research was on
the podcasting and he talked a lot about
the need for great design from the
get-go and spoke about who gets to make
decisions about how something is design
and we're not just talking about the
form factor we're talking about the
entire package and so with these new AI
systems how can we bring new people to
the table that really need to speak to
the design upfront into that traditional
system yeah this is something I think
about a lot and it requires really a
cultural shift right it's about
recognizing and understanding the skills
and expertise that each of these
different disciplines brings to the
table and how they can complement each
other in order to create responsible
systems that is just something that
requires education
it requires trying it out right like hey
if you do bring people in earlier you'll
likely create a better system because
now your decisions are driven by what's
actually going to be useful for people
I'm actually really hopeful right now
I joined MSR about seven years ago in
the machine learning group and I think
things were much different back then
right huh you know it was much harder
for me to explain like what I brought to
the table for machine learning you know
and why I was even there you know is the
first like HCI higher in the machine
learning group and it took a while
before people really understood what the
complementary skills that I brought to
the table that helped you know make
these things effective right and I think
people are more open to that now so even
though it requires this shift in our
industry I'm hopeful that it will happen
right well and Bill talked quite a bit
about the
fact that the arguments that you hear
are we don't have enough time we don't
have enough money we need to ship but
there are constraints that are inherent
in that cycle there are ways to plan for
this right like reserving some resources
for dealing with responsibilities is use
you know if you know they're gonna be
there so if you reserve some resources
for that then you don't run into this
problem of we don't have enough time or
resources I think another thing that
helps is calling these issues failures I
use the word failures really
intentionally because we used to call
responsibilities of issues you know
issues or problems but just that term
will put it lower in the priority stack
right but if you call it a failure like
if people are might get harmed or if
there's a bias against people like
that's a failure that's something that's
a showstopper right
you're not going to deploy something
that has a failure right so I think it's
important to talk about it that way so
that we ensure that we're actually
prioritizing fixing them AI brings both
new challenges and new opportunities in
innovation in user interface and user
experience you address this issue in a
paper that proposes guidelines for human
AI interaction from a research
perspective a development perspective
and a user perspective which i think is
cool talk about the genesis of this work
and the findings that you presented in a
paper at KY this year mm-hmm so we
created the guidelines because we were
really seeing that our product teams and
practitioners were struggling to design
for AI and I spoke about this a bit
earlier which is you know this fact that
AI systems are fundamentally different
from traditional computing systems so
they're going to be inconsistent they're
going to be error prone so what we know
about designing for traditional systems
doesn't always work this is evidenced by
just the failures that we see every day
in the news you know have range from
like funny like auto completion
errors to like really harmful errors and
at the same time there's actually been a
lot of research advances over the last
like 20 years around how to develop
these types of AI systems
effectively and for me that was somewhat
frustrating seeing sort of people
struggle and missing out on some of
what's been going on in the academic
community or industrial circles and I
felt that there was a lot of sort of
reinventing the wheel and wasted time
and that's you know partly because
guidance is really scattered across many
different industrial circles guidance
that is available it hasn't always been
evaluated in a wide variety of scenario
so if you know something works well for
like a bot how do you know what's gonna
work well for any other AI system and
sometimes the guidance is presented at
very different altitudes like you can
have really high-level guidance like
make sure these things are you know
trustworthy but like how do you do that
right what does it even mean exactly
right like so we wanted to provide
guidance that was more actionable right
so we got together with a large group of
people and said like hey let's just try
to synthesize what we know across the
industry and come up with guidance
that's clear actionable and that we know
is relevant to a wide variety of
scenarios so we went through this
iterative process we collected guidance
and best practice recommendations from a
wide variety of sources I think we have
like 200 to begin with and then we
iteratively group them revise them
tested them with real practitioners to
understand if they were really something
that people could detect and notice in
interfaces and that's how we develop
them we tried to take a really rigorous
and systematic approach so that we could
you know feel confident in recommending
these as things that we know are
tried-and-true and I think that helps
both you know researchers developers and
end-users you know it helps
practitioners design better systems that
gives the end users better systems to
use and I think it also helps accelerate
research because like I said you know I
thought that we were sort of reinventing
the wheel and I think by synthesizing
this work it can kind of reveal where
the real gaps in our knowledge are and
so we can try to then really push the
boundaries into what we don't know who's
this for I mean when you say guidelines
for human AI interact
who's your audience I would say
primarily practitioners so product teams
like we want them to you know have the
knowledge to create good systems but
also researchers like I said you know I
want to really advance the field here's
what we know now let's figure out and
improve the situation and do research in
areas that we have less knowledge you
currently chair a really interesting
working group at Microsoft on human AI
interaction and collaboration and it's a
part of Microsoft's ether effort which
is a company-wide initiative around
responsible AI and I know there's a lot
of Venn diagram overlap with this and
what we've been talking about up to this
point but I want you to drill in a
little bit on why the issue of human AI
collaboration warrants an actual group
or task force maybe as a good word and
who's involved like you said you know
much of what I've talked about today
actually came out of this working group
so that you know the studies about
people's perceptions around
responsibility AI failures the
guidelines work all came out of this
human area interaction and collaboration
working group which we called the hake
working group and you know just like you
know any new set of problems this is a
new space right like we don't know how
to do human AI interaction and
collaboration well yet and so we need
people to be really trying to push the
boundaries of this area you know people
with the right expertise in order to
make advances so that includes you know
coming up with new best practices and
techniques but also you even just
advancing the state of the art in terms
of the methodologies we use that's
something that we've been looking into
recently is that a lot of our techniques
and methodologies for building
traditional systems don't work that well
so you know we have in design we have
prototyping techniques like Wizard of Oz
techniques for example that's often used
to do early prototyping and testing but
that's really hard with AI systems
because it's hard to mimic the different
ways an AI system
well behaved but that means if you don't
have that in place then you need to take
a dependency on a model which means that
you can't sort of test your interface
early and that causes problems right so
we really need experts people who
understand human-computer interaction
user research methodologies and AI
systems to think deeply about new
methodologies to enable rapid
prototyping and iteration and other
methodologies for evaluation testing and
building AI systems let me drill in a
little bit there
technology advances at a very rapid pace
now maybe faster than it ever has and
you're a group who are a little bit
putting the brakes on and saying wait we
need to make sure this isn't gonna harm
anybody how much influence do you have
among the various groups of people that
are putting this technology out so I
would characterize it not necessarily
that we're putting the brakes on things
yes we're trying to make sure we think
carefully and thoughtfully about how to
build these systems so not since we
might need to slow things down but we're
also trying to push the boundaries right
that means like coming up with new
techniques so we can then accelerate our
progress what are the new methodologies
and techniques and tools we need to
build so that we can still make rapid
progress but do so carefully so I kind
of see us as you know partially pressing
the base but partially you know pressing
the accelerator
[Music]
well Salima we've reached the part of
the podcast where I ask all my guests
the same thing what keeps you up at
night and obviously a lot of your work
is based on what keeps all of us up at
night I'm glad you're doing it ethical
AI is a huge issue here and you're
tackling it head-on
but that said not everyone's going to
comply with best practices so what kinds
of things can be done to mitigate the
undesirable consequences of these
powerful tools and ensure that I don't
lose any sleep at night yeah you know I
mean the space is like I said earlier
it's both exciting and terrifying for me
you know and I really believe that to
create ethical and responsible systems
we really need a diverse set of
perspectives at the table right this is
both at the macro level and the micro
level you know the macro level in terms
of coming up with policies like I think
we need policies around this but that
needs to be driven both by industries
and government agencies working together
right if you have just one of those
entities making decisions sometimes
they'll come up with things that just
don't work right and then at the micro
level you know building individual
products I really feel that we need
people with not only diverse backgrounds
in terms of you know race and ethnicity
and gender but also different skill sets
you know people with different
experiences different tools and
methodologies that you use how do we
enable these people to work together and
I think that's gonna require a cultural
shift which is hard to do but you know
I'm trying my best to have you know the
ether working group on fake human
interaction in collaboration this is
sort of what we were really trying to do
Microsoft Research is not a monolith
people come from all over here different
backgrounds and life experiences and
unique personal stories so tell us yours
Salima what got you started in computer
science and what landed you here at
Microsoft Research
I did my PhD at the University of
Washington which was really just across
the lake from Redmond here and so that
made it really easy to collaborate with
MSR and there was just so many
interesting people to work with and so I
ended up doing three internships here at
I'm sorry I just kept coming back and
even like when I wasn't doing
internships I would collaborate with
people I just always loved it I loved
the energy the breadth of experience and
expertise and everyone is just willing
to talk to you and work together and I
sort of always knew that I wanted to
come back here and so after grad school
you know I applied came here when I when
I first started you know people would
ask me if I was you know back for
another internship
well rewind before University of
Washington and your PhD what got a young
Salima a mercy interest where did you
start where are you from Washington
State etc so I grew up in Vancouver BC
yeah I went to UBC for undergrad and my
masters and it actually started off as a
math major in fact I never thought I
would go into computer science you know
wasn't like computers were just sort of
becoming common in high schools and I
wasn't really exposed to it that much
but I really liked math that's what I
wanted to do on a butte math professor
and so when I started undergrad at the
time you know you had to take computer
science courses as part of your math
major and that's I think when I got
really exposed to computer science which
is really about putting math to work you
know it's about making math do things
and do cool things you know and that's
when I started transitioning to computer
science and then I started working at
the laboratory for computational
intelligence at UBC working on
intelligent tutoring systems right
that's where I got exposed to AI systems
and then as I was building those systems
I found it was hard to do you know so I
was trying to make my life easier you
know hope by building better tools and
that's kind of what led me to HCI
and Here I am working now on this
intersection
what's one interesting thing a trait a
characteristic a life event a sidequest
the people might not know about you and
maybe it's impacted your career as a
researcher I think of myself as a
pragmatist and most of what's driven my
work I would say and driven the path
that I took was trying to make my own
life easier you know so when I was
working with intelligent tutoring
systems back at UBC I remember at that
time to build these things you would
create like these giant belief networks
that were hand tuned by experts for just
one system and that was like yes it was
powerful but it was not scalable and
that's what got me into machine learning
right it's like okay how do we do this
without having to hand tune all these
things so that's how I started using
machine learning for intelligent
tutoring systems then when I was using
machine learning like I said you know
the tools that we had for those for you
know data collection and cleaning and
understanding and debugging we're just
really hard to use and it was really
difficult there was a steep learning
curve so that's what got me into
interactive machine learning and HCI you
know because I wanted to create better
tools for myself you know build these
things more efficiently and effectively
and then you know at the same time I'm
not you know I build these systems but
I'm also a user right so when I interact
with these AI systems in my everyday
life you know like social networking
systems or recommender systems it really
frustrates to me when I can't do what I
want you know I can't steer these things
the way I want and I think that's about
giving everyday people the right
controls and knobs in order to steer
these things I think there's a myth that
people won't want to put in the time and
effort to interact with these or steer
their systems but I don't think that's
true you know I think if people start to
understand the benefits of doing so and
if you give them easy controls they'd be
willing to do so and so really it's
about helping myself you know making my
life easier
it in turn will help other people build
and use these things effectively at the
end of every show I give my guests a
chance to encourage inspire or even
instruct our listeners
pretty well in any way they see fit do
you have any parting words any thoughts
on what we might need from next-gen
researchers for next-gen technologies
yeah I really believe that there's so
many interesting opportunities to work
at the intersection of different fields
there's a lot of opportunities to bridge
different communities enable them to
work together more effectively to create
really novel solutions to our problems
so you know what I would recommend for
you know the students out there the next
generation of researchers is to explore
those opportunities and work across
interdisciplinary boundaries you know
train yourself in multiple different
fields so you can understand problems
that might be solved by bringing those
together I think that could really help
change the world
Salima Oh merci thank you so much for
joining us today thank you for having me
[Music]
to learn more about dr. Salima a mercy
and how researchers are working to make
AI robust and responsible visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]